oh hello everybody we're here with the
writer and director of Halloween ends
David Gordon green let's do a look
behind the scenes if you don't mind
because I love your body of work behind
the scenes it's like behind the scenes
[Music]
George Washington right opening scene of
the movie was never in the script but it
was two 12 year olds that were having a
little bit of a of a first love Crush
having a conflict I said let's film it
and I sat them down a room put a camera
on them and let him talk it out and it
inspired the rest of the film
Pineapple Express Pineapple Express was
a weird experiment in taking non-action
actors and putting them in an action
movie so everyone got hurt you know
James Franco split his head open on a
tree and so we had to put a headband on
him for most of the movie Danny McBride
got back of his head split open had to
get stitches Seth was uh was doing some
stunt where he was falling on a glass
table and broke a rib you know
it shows you the uh
that is not a time that we uh safely
went to dangerous places that was when
we were just idiots everybody loves such
a cult Obsession the righteous gemstone
okay yeah that's a fun one and uh a
great memory of our first season and
that there's a lot of male nudity in
that show you know Walton Goggins is a
great actor that I've worked with a
number of times and he plays an elderly
character but I wanted a scene of his
elderly character it's one thing to put
a wig and some makeup on but I wanted
this elderly character to be naked so we
did head replacement on an older man it
was really fun with Walt picking out who
was going to be you naked at 80 years
old
Halloween your first one 2018 your kick
off to the franchise every day with
Jamie Lee is just an exercise in energy
she comes in with this Fireball so you
just show up and it's just explosive in
what you're going to create and so there
are times when you are genuinely afraid
when you see things in the in in the
reflection or find these little these
shots and so that's a it's hard to find
that one because it's kind of every day
in that movie Halloween kills we've all
come to this movie to see Lori strobe
and Michael Myers in their confrontation
and there's a very violent scene that
has a moment of their hands interlocked
and there's blood everywhere we filmed
the scene and I see cut the camera the
Tilt falls down the actors don't let go
and I see where the camera's tilted into
the reflection of the blood and you see
the reflection of their hands in the
blood and then for the next 20 minutes
we turn the camera back on and we just
hold that moment we start dancing and it
was the craziest like graphic bloody
Jazz that we were we were performing
which in the actors the camera the
lighting Reflections and all these
things and it's those type of
Inspirations that really they keep me
drawn to the genre they keep me drawn to
filmmaking in the craft you know that's
a very confident unique director
Halloween ends my favorite part I don't
want to ruin anything what possessed
that moment like what was in your mind I
think you could say that I'll say it
there's a guy who gets his tongue cut
off yes and the way it's done and shot
at the moment moment it just it's there
forever it's a perfect example of when
you're making these movies you're like
that's never going to be in the movie
it's too much and and then we'll do the
suggested version of it and the story is
told but then you show it to a crowd and
people lose their minds and you're like
never mind it's in the movie listen we
did that with Supreme we went for full
commitment and I think that's what
people who do love this genre and the
fans may be like we're trying to make
sure to like live up to that like go all
the way sometimes and don't compromise
yeah I love it David Gordon green I
cannot thank you enough behind the
scenes be sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel for more behind the
scenes
[Music]